we're now going to zoom in on two
particular examples that go forward
different kinds of numbers okay and the
ones you've looked at before
more depth let's think of negatives
first
negative
again i want you to think what kind of
problem
would be solved that would need negative
numbers right
okay what's four minus three
one it's one right what's
three minus four
now you guys say negative one right you
should say negative one not minus one by
the
way
that's that's another story but you know
what you know
all those super crazy smart people from
the renaissance right or like the
the raphaels and the michelangelo's and
the
da vinci's right they would have said
this is this is you know what they'd say
they'd say no solution you know
in exactly the same way as when you get
a quadratic right
something like this x squared uh minus
x plus one okay you'd look at that
and you'd throw it into quadratic
formula and you'd say ah doesn't have a
solution
right but you guys know there is a
solution just not in terms of the
numbers that we looked at
that's what they said here yeah like you
can't
you can't have three things you can't
have three things
you can't have three things and take
away four that doesn't work in real life
you take
one away and then two away and then
three you can't take away any more
whiteboard markers right
but you guys know better don't you you
guys do better so so this was the kind
of problem
that negatives were designed to solve
okay they're weird because
because how can you have less than you
know one two
three less than nothing nothing itself
was a weird enough idea
okay now next row this is a new one
right
how long did it take for this idea to be
accepted right now
it's a bit tricky because depending on
what part of the world you're in there
are seven different times
but are you ready see this quote the
quote we looked we saw at the beginning
of the lesson right
it was spoken written rather in
1759
about negative numbers they said
these negative things right it's obvious
there's no solution to this
it's obvious and simple and now you're
making this dark and confusing and
there's this
huh like what does that mean right so
neganos were considered absurd at least
classicism
until the 1700s okay
so what does a negative mean how would
you explain it to someone
i think the idea is like what's the
difference between one or minus one
two and negative two right like when you
first
learnt negatives what did they tell you
the negative signified
what situations do we use them in
uh it's like look you've got um
you've got the sea water level right and
then you've got
underneath the sea there is you know
a submarine okay
and then up here you've got you've got
the plane right
it's beautiful okay looks like a space
shuttle actually anyway okay
so in a plane right it's above
and then you've got a submarine and it's
below right
so you can call the c level you can call
that zero
that would make this positive and
that'll make this negative right
or you could talk about like debts like
i've got money or i owe money
right so the intuitive meaning is that
these things
they're opposites right
that's the intuitive meaning that we get
from negatives up
down left right have money owe money
okay so
this might seem simple but how do
negatives work when you multiply them
this is really important for the next
bit that we're going to do
okay you start with one right
if you multiply it by a negative then
you'll get 10 minus one now what happens
when you multiply again
it comes back to one doesn't it if you
want to try again and again
and again this is how it cycles around
okay
so have that in that and when you think
about like a coordinate system right
what it means to have your positives 1 2
3
here right and your negatives over here
the meaning is well instead of going
forwards go backwards
that's what negatives mean in a
coordinate system
all right now here's where it starts to
get really fun right this is our last
bit that we're going to finish
complex numbers complex numbers we've
sort of very very
um in a very basic way and looked at
these okay
let's go through the same kinds of ideas
why were these numbers invented
what problem was i trying to solve
i've actually got one on the board
look we talked about how simple
quadratics are right it's not hard to
write something like that down and yet
you need to have these numbers to exist
to say oh it has a solution
and i can solve it why is it weird
because what number can you think of
that you multiply by itself and gives
you a negative we don't have numbers
like that
right that's that's really weird
what's the next thing um how long
have these numbers been considered
absurd uh well
based on how you guys reacted when i
first explained the idea
in some places they're still considered
absurd like still don't get it still
weird
okay okay now
i said negatives are about flipping back
and forth about opposites right
but complex numbers are not remember i
let's do this multiplication cycle and
i'll show you okay
this is what happens when you multiply
by negative numbers what happens if i
multiply
1 by i simple question you just get i
right what happens when you multiply
again
you get what do you get you get i
squared what's i squared though
it's negative one isn't it that's how we
defined it square to negative one yeah
okay what happens when i multiply by it
one more time
times i multiplied by i should be minus
i
right okay last time
i promised i want to multiply by i
again what happens
it'll be minus i squared which is minus
negative one
which is one okay so here it takes me
two like one one multiplication really
to get back to
the original right one two
one two okay but here it took me more it
took me
one two three four right
so the idea is instead of opposite and
instead of flipping
right the intuitive meaning is rotation
okay
here's one do you remember this i showed
you very briefly if i multiply by i
once you get to here
you multiply again you get to here
you multiply a third time look that's i
up there
so that's why this is minus i because
you're going down
and then you multiply the fourth time
and that gets you back
to where you started okay so it's
rotation